Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody. You may or may
not have heard this because you've probably
grown tired of yet another challenge to the
Affordable Care Act, but Obamacare, which is
the same thing as the ACA, remember, Obamacare
has survived another challenge and this one in
the Supreme Court via a seven to two decision,
which we're going to look at in a moment.
You know, at this point, it's time to stop even
thinking about Obamacare as this additional thing
on our health care system. You know, it's been 11
years. The fundamentals of Obamacare are just now
part of the not that great health care system that
we have in the United States. And increasingly,
I mean, at this point, dozens and dozens of
House votes when Republicans controlled the
House to try to undo it, various different legal
and constitutional challenges, Donald Trump and
four years of trying to gut it, despite the fact
that he had nothing sensible or reasonable to
replace it with. We just now have our health care
system and it includes some Obamacare provisions
and we now need to move forward from where we are.
But there are many who don't want to accept that,
and there are many who want to continue pretending
that there is still this appendage that is
Obamacare, which could just be clipped off very,
very easily. It's just part of our system at this
point in time. Let's look at some of the reporting
on this from CNBC. The Supreme Court ruled on
Thursday against Texas and other Republican
led states seeking to strike down Obamacare
in the law's latest test before the nation's
highest court. The top court voted seven to two
to reverse an appeals court ruling that had struck
down the law's individual mandate provision.
That is the provision that Donald Trump
very aggressively tried to attack, because
if you get rid of that, you are really doing
significant damage to the way Obamacare works.
Justice Stephen Breyer, who authored the opinion
of the court, said that Texas and the other states
that challenged the law failed to show that they
were harmed by it. In legal terms, the states
failed to demonstrate that they had standing.
Neither the individual nor the state plaintiffs
have shown that the injury they will suffer or
have suffered is fairly traceable to the allegedly
unlawful conduct of which they complain. The
decision is a major victory for the legislation,
which former President Barack Obama signed in
2010. It's a crucial element of the nation's
health care system. Joe Biden has vowed to expand
its reach. The decision marks the third time that
Obamacare has survived the challenge before the
Supreme Court. Defenders of the law worried that
the panel, which is now a six three Republican
appointed majority, would scrap the legislation,
which has long been criticized by conservatives.
Chuck Schumer said each time in each arena,
the Affordable Care Act has prevailed.
Going on to say, let me say definitively,
the Affordable Care Act has won. The Supreme Court
has ruled the ACA is here to stay. And now we're
going to try to make it bigger and better. What
a day. What is most frustrating to me about this
is that Obamacare did good things, but
it's really no incredible victory. It's not
God's gift since sliced bread or whatever
other metaphors and analogies you want me
to embarrassingly mix together. We really you
know, I've said before, Medicare for all is not
the only way. And I've spoken recently to other
people on the left who have a similar perspective.
If you look at what Germany has done with a
multi payer system, if you set up a system
where the health insurance companies exist, but
they must be non-profits and have to compete with
a government plan, if you want to do a combination
system like France has or in Amsterdam, I'm sorry,
in in in the Netherlands, in Holland, taxes are
higher than in the United States and people pay a
small fee for a comprehensive health care system.
At least my friend who works in Amsterdam does.
But overall, it's way cheaper than in
the United States. And you have access
and quality is quite good. There are other ways
that we can get everybody coverage that is good.
So this is not about it has to be Medicare
for all, which I would be very much open to.
This is about the fact that 11 years later, we're
still arguing about something that is, number one,
not a miraculously great thing, although it does
good things. And number two is not radical. The
fact that in other countries there are so
many phases beyond where we are and we're at
half the country or at least half the elected
officials want to get rid of Obamacare. The other
half want to keep it. Joe Biden. Wants a public
option, but there's real questions about whether
there any practical way that it's actually going
to be made a reality any time soon, which would
be a great failing for Joe Biden to be absolutely
and completely clear. It's humiliating that this
is even the conversation that's happening in the
United States when you look at every other country
that's at our level of wealth and our level of
development. And so, you know, when you ask me
what is the most disgusting thing about
this? Is it disgusting that Republicans,
when they had the House, had like 60 something
votes to try to repeal Obamacare even though it
was going to go nowhere? Yes, that's disgusting.
Is it disgusting that Republicans continue to try
to work within the legal system at different state
level courts all the way up to the Supreme Court,
and that Trump made it such a priority during
his presidency to get rid of Obamacare,
even though he had nothing sensible to replace it
with? All of that stuff is disgusting. There's no
question about it whatsoever. But the really crazy
part to me is that this is so milquetoast. This is
so we listen. It's good health care dot gov. It's
good that it was created keeping people to age 20,
up to twenty six on parent's insurance. That's
good. Preexisting conditions. It's good.
It's not that those things aren't good, it's crazy
that those things even needed to be done in 2010.
But the fact that 11 years have gone by and other
than some really small tweaks, mostly because of
coronavirus, we are not anywhere beyond Obamacare
and there are still efforts being made to get rid
of it. That's actually the disgusting part, that
it's something so milquetoast and unremarkable.
So Obamacare survived again in the Supreme Court.
Great. Now, maybe we can find something else to
actually get done over this 11 year period during
which it's been basically just fending off attacks
on Obamacare from Republicans. I don't know. I
don't know. We'll follow and see what happens up.